رب لحدا قد صار لحدا
[موسيقى]
ميرا
را ضاحكا من تزاحم الاطباد ينتظر المعري
ان تلمح بصيرته العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
هنا سيقف غريبا مهجيرا او ربما لاجئا
ككثير ممن ابعدتهم الحرب من ابناء وطنه
تشابهت قصته مع قصتهم يوم دمر الجهل
والاستبداد تمثاله ومعظم مسقط راسه معره
النعمان ها هنا يجد ابو العلا من لا
يجهلون قدره لا من
هذه ذكرى الرجل الذي انار درب اجيال من
المفكرين
المعري كان شاعرا كان عالما وعقلا فريدا
ومفكرا حرا حارب طوال حياته من اجل الحريه
والعداله الاجتماعيه في تحدي الطغاه وافقت
فرنسا على نصب التمثال في احدى ساحاتها
على ان يعود يوما ما لمسقط راسه مره اخرى
يشابه تمثال معري بلاده في الامل انجز
التمثال في غرناطه الاندلس باسبانيا مبعد
اخر عن وطنه اعاد بناءه هناك
حاولت اعبر عن
عن شاعر فيلسوف
يرى اكثر بالبصيره من البصر
لذلك فرغت العينتين
وهلقتانة اللي بتشوفها خلالها هي بصيرته
استقطبت فرنسا خلال العقد الماضي كثيرا من
الفنانين والادباء والمثقفين السوريين
الفارين من استبداد النظام
اساس بعضهم مبادره ناجون وهي تجمع لاولئك
الذين حالفهم الحظ بالنجاه من المعتقلات
بتمويل جماعي من اولئك الناجين وعد بناء
التمثال يعني كان الدافع والاساسي لهذه
المبادره وهذا المشروع هو يعني فعلا انه
نحن نخرج من مستنقع المظلوميه ونسبه حالنا
كسوريين انداد عرفت كيف وشركاء بالمجتمعات
المضيفه لنا
ونتجنب هذا الخطاب اللي بيقطرنا يعني نحن
بصفه الضحايا
نظم الحدث بالتزامن مع مرور 12 عاما على
الثوره السوريه كانت ذكراها فرصه تذاكر
فيها المهجرون اسباب الهجره واللجوء يجد
المعري لنفسه موطئ قدم في المهجر في وقت
يظن فيه الوطن بامتار قليله على رموزه
ومبدعيه احياء كانوا امواتا ينتصب هنا وفي
الفضاء صدم من شعره اذ يقول وقد صار ذكري
في الحياه فمن لهم
باخفاء شمس
ضوءها متكامل محمود الزيبق الجزيره
باريس